>> Geraldo: THE DEAL IS DONE.
ELON MUSK SAYS HE'S THE CHIEF
TWIT OF THE SOCIAL MEDIA GIANT.
HE WALTZED IN TO THE
SAN FRANCISCO HEADQUARTERS
BRANDISHING A BATHROOM SINK.
A REALITY HAS SUNK IN FOR THE
WOKE EMPLOYEES.
MUSK SAID IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
FUTURE OF CIVILIZATION TO HAVE A
COMMON DIGITAL TOWN SQUARE.
HE'S PROMISING ADVERTISERS THAT
TWITTER WON'T BE A FREE FOR ALL
HELL SCAPE.
THAT MAY BE FALLING ON DEAF
EARS.
530 EMPLOYEES HAVE CALLED IT
QUITS AT TWITTER.
THOSE THAT STAYED ARE DEMANDING
LEADERSHIP DOES NOT DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST WORKERS ON THEIR RACE,
GENDER OR POLITICAL BELIEFS.
CRITICS QUICK TO POINT OUT THAT
SOME OF THE SAME EMPLOYEES USED
POLITICAL BELIEFS TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
CONSERVATIVES.
SO DO YOU LIKE MUSK?
>> Jeanine: I DO LIKE MUSK.
>> Geraldo: WHAT DO YOU THINK
WILL BE DIFFERENT IN TWITTER?
>> Jeanine: HE WON'T SUPPRESS
CONSERVATIVE VOICES.
HE WILL MAKE IT -- WHAT DOES HE
SAY?
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE A FREE FOR
ALL HELL SCAPE.
>> Geraldo: ARE YOU ON TWITTER?
>> Jeanine: YEAH.
HE ALSO SAID THAT HE WANTS TO
TAKE IT PUBLIC IN A FEW YEARS,
WHICH MEANS THAT HE WANTS TO
MAKE IT A MONEY -- HE'S GOT TO
MAKE IT SUCCESSFUL.
THOSE PEOPLE THAT QUIT, THEY'VE
GOT TO BE PEOPLE THAT KNOW THAT,
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE
FOR MAKING SURE THAT CERTAIN
OPINIONS HAVE BEEN SQUASHED.
AND ALSO I THINK HE SHOULD CLEAN
HOUSE TOTALLY.
I THINK HE'S TOTALLY RIGHT.
CLEAN HOUSE.
I LIKE THE SINK ANALOGY.
I THINK IT'S GREAT.
>> Geraldo: WHEN YOU PAY $44
BILLION FOR A WEBSITE BASICALLY,
YOU BETTER HAVE YOUR SAY.
>> Jesse: HE OVERPAID.
HE KNOWS IT.
>> Geraldo: HE DID.
>> Jesse: HE'LL HAVE HIS SAY.
IT'S A BLOATED COMPANY.
THE HEAD COUNT IS BLOATED.
HE WILL HAVE TO CUT STAFF.
THEY'RE NOT MAKING ANY MONEY.
LIBERALS DIDN'T CARE.
LET'S JUST HIGH 100,000 WORKERS,
NOT MAKE ANY MONEY.
WHAT IS THE PROBLEM?
THE PROBLEM IS YOU'RE LOSING
MONEY AND YOU'RE CORRUPTING THE
COUNTRY.
HE WILL COME IN AND HAVE A RED
WAVE.
YOU HAVE HUNTER BIDEN
INVESTIGATIONS GOING AFTER THE
RED WAVE AND YOU HAVE MUSK
RUNNING TWITTER, THIS IS THE
DEMOCRATS WORST NIGHTMARE.
>> Geraldo: I DON'T KNOW.
WHEN YOU PAY $44 BILLION, YOU
SHOULD HAVE YOUR RIGHT TO
INNOVATE.
HE'S AN INNOVATOR.
>> Dana: YEAH.
THAT IS A GOOD START.
>> Geraldo: WHAT ABOUT INVITING
TRUMP BACK?
>> Dana: I THINK MUSK HAD SAID
IF HE WERE TO TAKE OVER, HE WILL
DO IT.
WE'LL WAIT AND SEE.
IF I WAS AN EMPLOYEE THERE, I
WOULD BE CURIOUS.
OKAY.
DOES HE HAVE A WAY TO MAKE IT
BETTER?
THEY LOVE HIM NOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL VEHICLES.
THEY LOVE HIM NOR THE FACT OF
STAR LINK AND THE FACT THAT HE'S
PROVIDING INTERNET ACCESS TO THE
PEOPLE OF UKRAINE WHILE THEY'RE
BEING POUNDED BY RUSSIA.
MAYBE JUST GIVE HIM A SECOND.
>> Geraldo: GREAT ADVICE.
GIVE HIM A SECOND.
WHAT ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE HAS
BECOME A REAL FORCE IN TERMS OF
COMMENTING ON UKRAINE WITH USING
STAR LINK AS LEVERAGE, COMMENTED
ON TAIWAN AND CHINA SHOULD HAVE
SOME INFLUENCE THERE.
HE SAYS SOME BOMB SHELL THINGS
THAT, YOU KNOW, MAYBE WE SHOULD
WORRY A LITTLE BIT OR SHOULD WE
ABOUT CHECKS AND BALANCES?
>> Greg: RIGHT NOW I HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE.
THAT POEM RED WHEELBARROW AUTHOR
WAS WRONG, THIS IS MY LAST SHOW
AT FOX.
I LOVE HOW THE TWITTER STAFF IS
WORRIED ABOUT THE
DISCRIMINATION.
NO LONGER CAN THEY DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST POLITICAL BELIEFS, A
FREE FOR ALL HELL SCAPE SOUNDS
FUN.
PERMISSION TO USE AN ANALOGY.
IT WAS ONE THAT YOU USED.
THE MRS. DOUBTFIRE ANALOGY.
TWITTER IS MRS. DOUBTFIRE AND
THE ALGORITHM IS ROBIN WILLIAMS.
MUSK KNOWS WHAT'S UNDER THE HOOD
AND MUSK WILL SHOW WHAT IS
THERE.
THESE ARE ONLY PEOPLE THAT SEE
CERTAIN NEWS PERSPECTIVES BASED
ON AN ALGORITHM.
HE KNOWS WHAT IT IS.
HE'S NOT A SCIENTIST.
HE MAY YOU'RE IN PHILOSOPHY AND
ECONOMICS.
I'M NOT SURE.
HE MASTERED THE ELECTRIC
BATTERY, MASTERED SPACE
EXPLORATION.
THAT WILL BE A NO BRAINER FOR
HIM AND HE'S NOT DOING IT
BECAUSE HE HAS TO.
HE'S NOT DOING IT BECAUSE HE
WANTS TO.
HE JUST DECIDED TO DO IT.
HE REALIZED THIS TWITTER HAS
REALLY BEEN SCREWING UP THIS
COUNTRY.
HE KNOWS IT.
>> Geraldo: HE'S BEEN QUOTING
E.E. CUMMINGS.
I TRUST MUSK AS MUCH ANSWER I
TRUST "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
EDITORIAL BOARD.
I THINK THEY